votre invité ce matin Sony Mabrouk à la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel
bienvenue sur Europe 1 et bonjour Sarah
Eric bonjour nous parlerons si vous le
voulez bien foot tout à l'heure mais il
y a d'abord un autre match au combien
important qui se jouent sur la réforme
des retraites la présentation et donc
repousser au 10 janvier annoncé Emmanuel
Macron le président se justifiait en
évoquant les élections chez LR et Europe
Écologie les vers sérieusement pourquoi
ne pas donner la vraie raison très
sérieusement il se trouve que la réforme
des retraites est absolument nécessaire
elle est nécessaire pour notre pays pour
l'équilibre de nos comptes et pour dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont on ne
peut pas envisager de baisser les
pensions de retraite à nos retraités et
donc il faut cette réforme il faut une
réforme d'âge il faut une réforme plus
juste et pour ça et bien il faut
embarquer tout le pays la réforme des
retraites ce n'est pas un affrontement
ce sont des coalitions que le 10 janvier
vous allez embarquer tout le pays et
bien écoutez hier j'étais avec le
président de la République et la
première ministre à l'Élysée dans le
cadre du CNR et même si ce n'est pas le
lieu de la discussion autour de la
réforme des retraites les forces vives
de notre pays doivent partir de la même
ligne de départ celle ce des chiffres
ceux du constat François bayroule a
encore rappelé ce week-end avec une
publication d'une note en particulier
sur quel est l'état de nos retraites
quel est l'état du financement et bien
aujourd'hui il est nécessaire de
discuter avec les partis politiques et
les organisations syndicales plus que
jamais pour que cette réforme réussisse
il faut qu'on soit d'accord sur la ligne
de départ alors ça c'est très important
ce que vous dites ça aura les risques
c'est une nuance par rapport au ministre
vous dites qu'on n'est pas tous d'accord
sur la ligne de départ et vous insistez
si j'entends bien sur ce qu'a dit
François Bayrou c'est le présent de
votre partie c'est-à-dire l'alerte sur
le déficit 30 milliards d'euros pour une
addition substantielle est-ce que c'est
une pierre dans le jardin de certains
parlementaires et des syndicats
aujourd'hui bien sûr et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut discuter de cette ligne de
départ pour qu'on soit d'accord sur les
réponses et peut-être ne pas être
d'accord sur les réponses mais au moins
le constat est partagé je vais vous
donner un exemple très clair quand on
discute ou quand on regarde les débats
parlementaires à l'Assemblée nationale
ou au Sénat et que vous avez des
parlementaires qui disent notre régime
n'est pas déficitaire pourquoi alors la
question n'est pas quels sont les
réponses c'est pourquoi faut-il une
réforme et donc la question c'est il ne
faut pas de réforme à l'inverse si on
est tous d'accord sur la réalité de
l'équilibre et donc du déséquilibre on
est tous d'accord pour dire et bien il
faut trouver comment garder ce régime
par répartition et donc la discussion se
fait sur les mesures et non pas sur le
fondement même de la langue de me donner
la raison pour laquelle ce projet a été
décalé non les discussions
sont en cours et ça fait partie
aujourd'hui avec de nouvelles forces
vives politiques et syndicales contenus
des élections aussi dans la fonction
publique et bien quelques semaines
supplémentaires apporteront les voix et
moyen pour réussir cette réforme
François Bayero c'est là empêcheur de
tourner en rond c'est poils à gratter à
chaque fois c'est une sorte de
d'intelligence et de garantie pour c'est
c'est celui en qui je crois et dans le
fond il apporte quelque chose de une
sorte dame de sentiment de qu'est-ce que
le pays et je crois que effectivement
objectiver moi je fais confiance en
français si on leur donne les moyens de
voir notre système dans le détail et
bien il y a pas de raison que c'est très
du mal à comprendre votre position
c'est quand même particulier vous êtes
au gouvernement donc solidaire de cette
réforme et de la méthode et de la
méthode et en même temps en tant que
modem le patron de votre partie ne cesse
de critiquer le gouvernement et il dit
qu'à un manque de pédagogie il peut il
challenge la méthode il challenge la
manière de le faire c'est différent
et aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est
que nous portons cette réforme parce que
elle est nécessaire elle est nécessaire
vous savez pour les jeunes quand ceux
que je croise me disent je n'aurais pas
bien sûr il vous parle de cette réforme
de retraite aujourd'hui qu'ils auront
une retraite ils te disent mais je
n'aurais rien donc dans le fond ça ne me
concerne pas et moi mon job c'est dire
mais si l'acceptabilité de l'impôt
l'acceptabilité de notre modèle social
passe par la garantie d'avenir et
l'acceptabilité de l'âge 64 ou 65 ans
écoutez moi je crois que tout est tout
est ouvert non non mais écoutez on a eu
on a eu des débats pendant l'élection
présidentielle la question de de l'âge a
été posée plus d'une fois moi ce que je
sais c'est que 64 ou 65 dépendra des
mesures aussi pour aller chercher de
l'emploi senior aujourd'hui on a un
seigneur sur deux qui est au chômage et
donc plus on challenge plus on évitera
les moyens pour le retour à l'emploi des
personnes les plus âgées qui sont en
pleine forme en réalité plus on réussira
l'accepter ça dépend aussi de parcours
des catégories sociales exactement il y
a des métiers qui a des métiers qui
abîment des métiers qui cassent ce n'est
pas la même chose pour tout le monde et
donc ce regard très humain sur les fins
de carrière est nécessaire avec beaucoup
d'humanité mais surtout garantir le
pouvoir d'achat des personnes qui ont
travaillé donc ce n'est pas encore fixé
64 65 ans c'est un débat ouvert à
l'heure c'est toute la qualité du débat
aujourd'hui porter au sein du
gouvernement avec aussi surtout les
organisations syndicales et demain les
parlementaires vous savez je suis député
plus que jamais je ne prenne pas ses
débats vous êtes députés vous êtes aussi
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel vous êtes franco-marocaine ça
ne vous gêne pas qu'on le précise c'est
totalement assumé totalement française
avec un attachement réel pour le Maroc
ah mais vous savez moi aujourd'hui c'est
cette question qui est qui est presque
étonnante et que j'aimerais qu'il
n'existe pas cette question non
j'aimerais qu'elle n'existe pas mais je
la comprends je l'ai pas encore posé
d'ailleurs mais c'est là je comprends
parce que vous savez pourquoi je suis
ministre du gouvernement français je
suis élu de la République député élu
local de Nantes ma journée est faite
pour porter améliorer le quotidien des
Français je défends nos valeurs je
défends nos principes sans compromission
sans relativisme et avec tout ça et bien
il y a toujours parfois une suspicion et
bien d'aller les gens moi j'ai envie de
France j'en ai même fait un livre je
l'ai écrit cet amour pour la Francie
puis si on a de gens c'est dur qu'on
peut on même sur un plan sportif on vous
reproche peut-être d'être davantage du
côté du Maroc avec cette affiche qui
vient entre la France et le Maroc en
tout cas la question est posée et si
elle est posée moi la réponse a toujours
été très simple et très claire moi j'ai
envie qu'on aille chercher cette
troisième étoile sur notre maillot parce
que je crois que c'est un élan et c'est
et c'est j'ai envie de ramener cette
coupe du monde et ce serait la première
fois qu'on a cette Coupe du monde avec
deux victoires consécutives mais pour
autant on a le droit on a le droit de
célébrer la victoire d'une note nation
et heureusement notre pays n'est pas la
négation des célébrations des joies ou
encore de son histoire et c'est là où il
faut faire extrêmement attention je
crois alors vous parlez de la joie on
aimerait que ce soit que de la joie et
des scènes de joie mais malheureusement
il y a des débordements il y a des
violences vous êtes vous n'êtes pas dans
le déni généralement Shannara mais
justement de quoi ces images qu'on a vu
dans plusieurs villes de France
notamment à Paris sur les Champs-Élysées
sont-elles le symptôme selon vous moi
j'ai vu des images qui étaient
différentes entre Paris et le reste de
la France principalement j'ai vu des
villes comme Pau ou il y avait autant de
drapeaux français que de drapeau
marocains ou d'autres drapeaux étrangers
et j'ai vu les Champs-Élysées comme vous
avec des espèces de voyous qui ont aussi
cassé la fête en cassant des vitrines ou
des kéké sur des scooters des petits
voyous des petits délinquants ce qui est
certain c'est que ces petits délinquants
et ces voyous on doit avoir une
tolérance zéro pour eux mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi il faut que ce soit
une double tolérance zéro je tiens
pourquoi la première chose c'est parce
que d'abord il casse et gâchent la fête
ça c'est le premier point mais en plus
ils alimentent le vote de l'extrême
droite parce que résultat des courses
bien sûr résultat des courses on entend
quoi on entend c'est un monsieur avant
qu'ils alimentent
typiquement les propos de monsieur
Zemmour dimanche dire que l'équipe du
Sénégal n'a pas assez de blanc ou
l'équipe de France a trop de noir depuis
quand être français est une couleur de
peau jamais ça ne le sera jamais
attendez avant on va venir au propos de
d'Éric Zemmour notamment que dont vous
parlez mais quand on s'attaque à des
policiers c'est ça ce dont il est
l'objet donc à l'autorité à ce qui
incarne la République est-ce qu'on
s'attaque aussi à la France est-ce
qu'elle représente vous dites cette
petite voyou à quoi ça tactile est-ce
que c'est juste brûler des des motos et
des scooters parce que c'est elle est
plus loin j'ai toujours de haine par
rapport à la France n'est pas arrivé
parents au Maroc non moi j'ai une
fermeté sans nom qu'on s'attaque aux
forces de l'ordre aux enseignants on a
vu toutes les formes d'autorité on a vu
ces images et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
être extrêmement extrêmement dur
extrêmement ferme engager la
responsabilité de leurs parents quand ce
sont des mineurs engager leur mais pour
aller mais il faut il faut aller
chercher ça parce que si on ne protège
pas les figures d'autorité dans notre
pays et donc si juridiquement on voulait
dire
ne sont pas exemplaires alors on en voit
pas un message responsabilité et donc
c'est c'est pour le coup c'est petit
voyou quand c'est des mineurs finissent
dans une sorte de toute puissance il ne
faut pas l'autoriser et donc attention
quand on porte un uniforme on est aussi
un symbole ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième et pour le coup c'est
malheureux chez nous mais à chaque fois
qu'on a un événement qu'on a une
manifestation ça dégénère mais pourquoi
ce qui pose la question de la violence
quoi mais plus largement au-delà de la
question de la nationalité parce que
parce qu'il y a un constat d'échec de
l'intégration de l'assimilation
aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y a une partie d'une de notre
jeunesse une partie d'entre elles ou
dans notre pays qui
n'a pas dans son cœur cet amour pour la
France et je crois que c'est tout la
mission qu'elle a mienne entre autres
celle par l'école par l'engagement par
le service national par le service vaste
défi quand on n'a pas l'amour de la
France et parfois quand on a la haine de
la France je préfère un pays qu'on a
peut-être parfois pas connu et bien il
faut casser ses fantasmes que ce soit
que ce soit l'Algérie le Maroc la
Tunisie mais attention l'Espagne
l'Argentine la Colombie peu importe
l'autre pays il faut casser le fantasme
de l'autre et donc finalement être
français et c'est là où il faut aller le
chercher être français c'est faire
allégeance à des principes à des valeurs
à une histoire et retomber amoureux de
cette idéale mais il faut rappeler
qu'elle nous donne on a envie de vous
entendre ça râlerait mais vous-même vous
avez eu à défendre d'ailleurs la France
et ses valeurs je pense c'était en
octobre 2020 juste après l'assassinat
terroriste de Samuel Paty vous avez dû
face à des lycéens dans une classe
défendre avec vigueur le droit au
blasphème réfuter le racisme supposé de
la police française marquez les limites
sur la religion à l'école est-ce qu'il y
a une rupture avec une partie de ces
jeunes je crois que c'était un moment
très très vif oui c'était un moment
c'était un moment important et c'était
un moment qui pour moi faisait aussi un
déclic puisque de fait c'est parti de la
l'écriture de du livre envie de France
parce que j'avais face à moi une partie
de notre jeunesse qui ne voyait pas
qu'ils étaient français et donc ils
avaient une d'autres aspiration et plein
de fantasmes et fondamentalement il faut
tenir des dicks et pour tenir des digues
il faut aller chercher ce choix
finalement d'aimer la France et de le
réveiller ils oublient qu'elle aura tout
donné l'école la santé la protection il
faut créer cette rencontre cette cette
capacité à s'émerveiller pour ses
valeurs pour son histoire pour ses
symboles pour ses héros et pour ça il
faut je crois purger une sorte d'abcès
être binational ce n'est pas être
schizophrène la bination d'été ce n'est
pas la schizophrénie la cime
l'assimilation l'intégration c'est dans
le fond c'est choisir d'être français
mais ça veut pas dire de te demander de
nier la richesse de l'histoire de tes
parents ni la tienne ça nous sommes
évident mais quand par exemple on vient
vêtu par exemple d'une habaya à l'école
ce vêtement religieux est-ce que c'est
une question encore de laïcité parce que
c'est une question de mœurs et de
culture française fondamentalement là
c'est le fruit d'une offensive
d'idéologie d'Islam radicale qui est
poussé sur les réseaux sociaux et pour
le coup faut pas se tromper là il n'y a
aucune question d'identité c'est une
question d'offensive d'un d'une
idéologie politique et donc c'est une
atteinte à la laïcité parce que cet
abaya en réalité quand elle est portée
c'est volontairement pour pousser nos
digues et nos lois
est un sanctuaire il y a des règles
qu'on ne qu'on doit protéger vrai lettre
d'autant plus que c'est bien le lieu qui
permet cette intégration c'est par c'est
par l'éveil des esprits oui mais alors
comment aider les professeurs vous avez
vu ce ressent sondage un enseignant sur
deux c'est déjà censuré par peur des
incidents j'ai l'impression que rien n'a
vraiment changé après l'énorme choc de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty rien ne se
passe de la même manière avant et après
malheureusement il faut rappeler les
choses la décapitation de Samuel Paty
parce que le poids des mots compte ce
n'était ça a été l'horreur sur notre
tête sur notre territoire et cette
horreur elle a permis de choses d'abord
le courage de Jean-Michel Blanquer qui a
permis et bien de poser les questions et
bien des valeurs de la République de la
laïcité renforcée parce que les
ministres
toutes les critiques face à cela sauf
que moi je l'ai vu entre les deux heures
je l'ai vu dans la dans les actes il a
renforcé les équipes de valeur de la
République il a renforcé également dans
la continuité la loi la protection de la
loi de 2004 et je suis avec lui au
quotidien donc je peux vous l'assurer
que les incidents d'ailleurs baisse mais
est-ce que ce n'est pas une auto-censure
de chiffre mais moi il y a une
auto-censure moi je le sens je le vois
c'est la réalité et là on a une
responsabilité collective la laïcité on
peut pas la mettre sur le sein des
épaules des enseignants ça serait ça
serait large de notre part les parents
doivent prendre leur part les
associations doivent prendre leur parc
et le débat politique aussi et c'est là
où il faut pas se tromper quand je dis
les parents quand vous laissez votre
fille partir avec une tenue qui est
inadéquate pour l'école il faut se poser
la question nous sommes en France elle
part à l'école on sait très bien que les
signes ostentatoires ne sont pas ne sont
pas acceptés ils sont même interdits et
l'école ce n'est pas un lieu comme les
autres donc on part pas à l'école comme
on part à la plage par contre après la
charge des parents la responsabilité des
parents nous avons la responsabilité
collectivement de faire de la laïcité et
bien oui un combat une reconquête on a
considéré que c'était un acquis la
preuve que non ce n'est plus un acquis à
l'école une question sur l'université
vous parlez souvent et pour les dénoncer
de cette théorie walk j'imagine vous
êtes plutôt spontanément du côté de
cette professeur de danse à Sciences Po
qui n'a pas voulu parler de follower
leader on lui a imposé en tous les cas
au lieu de dire homme femme est-ce que
ça vous est-ce que ça vous choque est-ce
que c'est comme certains disent une
minorité où est-ce que c'est
véritablement cette théories une
gangrène aujourd'hui qui s'installe dans
les facultés sciences je connais pas le
détail de la situation de Sciences Po
parce qu'on a vu les propos de Sciences
Po et puis à propos de l'enseignante
donc je m'exprimerai pas sur ce cas
particulier mesquin c'est que déjà je
n'aime pas les propos en anglais nous
sommes en France on a suffisamment de
beaux on a une langue suffisamment belle
et riche pour trouver les mots nommer
les choses nommer les genres femme homme
ce n'est pas un drame bon sang donc il
faut arrêter de se faire tyranniser pour
le coup par une minorité et ça tyrannisé
on le voit on le voit principalement
c'est vrai sur les réseaux sociaux il y
a une minorité qui essaye et bien de
cliver de diviser quasi à ne plus nommer
les choses ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut je crois avec beaucoup de bon
sens pouvoir et bien au sein de nos
universités en particulier continuent à
débattre ne pas limiter les propos
continuez à avoir ce truc si français
qui est presque un génie français et
bien de la conversation du débat c'est
quand même ça l'héritage des lumières et
bon sang on en est malheureusement un
petit peu privé parfois merci beaucoup
Sarah merci d'avoir été notre invité
d'avoir répondu une très bonne journée à
vous bonne journée à vous